yeah the Stars kind of a line today I
was laying around I wanted to do like a
nonsensical rambling video not
necessarily a review sometimes you just
want to talk about nonsense and
things that may or may not be happening
then it was announced JK Simmons has
officially been cast as James Gordon in
the DC Cinematic Universe for the
Justice League movie and I was like they
probably don't want to hear me talk
about that on Twitter you guys were like
this was like alright so I'll talk about
that first of all I am pumped about this
JK Simmons is one of the best actors
working right now if he wants to be Jim
Gordon I'll be like fantastic if he
wanted to be the piano in the movie the
piano I would be on this camera going
that is fantastic to know right now he's
walking around his house going
I'm Jim Gordon seriously this wonderful
news it's really funny Jay jonah jameson
and the Raimi's spider-man movies and
now he's Jim Gordon I think he just he
should hit up every universe man who's
gonna be in the x-men movie who's he
gonna be an infinity war I do wonder how
big a role he's going to play in the
Justice League movie I mean I feel like
Jim Gordon should have been in Batman vs
Superman somewhere but he just got cast
so I doubt he is or maybe he should have
been in the Suicide Squad movie
somewhere he just got cast it's possible
to shoehorn a man but I really doubt
he's gonna be in there feel like either
of those might have some gotham city
isms because batman is in both of those
movies Batman will obviously be and
Justice League also but at the point
that Justice League rolls around I feel
like they're going to be taking on
Darkseid at that point because in Batman
vs Superman we see some visions where
Batman is having visions about Planet
apocalypse which is where Darkseid is
from I believe their visions anyway my
last one I was like no they go to
apocalypse some people like I think
they're visions knows like I like that
explanation as a good one I'm gonna go
with that but if they're taking on
Darkseid what is Jim Gordon really gonna
do I just don't want it to be one of
those things where you have this awesome
actor cast is Jim Gordon who's not
really gonna do much it's possible and
really wanted to happen where Jim Gordon
plays this huge pivotal role in helping
the Justice League take on a super evil
demigod or do we just go ahead and call
him a god because holy he's pretty
powerful but I feel like Batman Superman
and the rest of this Justice League are
gonna be like hey thanks Jim Gordon nice
having you around you bring your
pom-poms to rout us on while we take on
the big bad guy because it's probably
how that's gonna go down cuz oh my god
he will waste you or are they bringing
him in to kill him I really hope not
also
but ms possible you guys remember that
Superman cartoon that was in the 90s
Darkseid comes in he starts wrecking the
earth believe it was a two-parter
because Superman beats him and Darkseid
is leaving he says remember even victory
has its price and he shoots out his
lasers and it goes around someone and
then hits the dude that was pretty much
the Jim Gordon of the Superman show and
just vaporizes oh this is big shocker
like holy but are they gonna just I
think I bring in Jack use him as a
dealer who knows I don't know this is
all speculation that's the point of this
video but the point is I'm really pumped
at JK Simmons has been cast as James
Gordon I think that's awesome I think
that's badass
I think he's a great actor anytime you
can get Cave Johnson in anything let's
do it so any other accomplished roles
dude's done I'm like you're Dave Johnson
for portal 2 we all know that and we all
love that boy thing I could call it Jim
Gordon in this video did I call him
Commissioner Gordon once or was it just
Jim first-name basis it's just
friendship right there are so JK Simmons
being cast as Commissioner Gordon what
do you think about that whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more